[Musique]
moi c'est du l'hiver et ma famille elle
est traître à recomposer nouvelles les
uns sur les autres
cet été on part en vacances chacun de
son côté avec eux jusqu'au 26 gilbert
quand je le récupère le 26 pour qu'on la
voit pas chez ta mère ta porte quoi
bonjour je m'appelle par la mise à mal
des rides
première règle avant 14h ne compte pas
sur moi et après 17 heures c'est pareil
c'est l'heure de l'apéro grand mère ça
sert à faire tout ce qui est admis par
les bandes c'est bon tu commences à ce
poste eric magnifique super et s'éclater
m'appelle pas venir le sauver culinaire
parce que tu fais n'importe quoi tu as
très bien d'autant que je me sentais pas
retouché trois points
ce soir c'est toi qui vous fait le
report tortionnaires qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec les aubergines on voulait un
devoir envers 20 heures pour les petits
à 21h pour les grandes vacances chez
mamie aurore c'est aussi les vacances de
mam your allé all-in à lui je ne le
vendrai qu'une seule fois qui va venir
en boîte avec moi elles sont pas
majeures ce monde et le tout petit je
suis là j'ai mon père est ce que tout ça
hein suivante une bande dans son lit
vieil homme avait pour thème fort à
loulou les amours rapport à t1 seulement
viser la lauze tous qu'il est beau temps
france des voleuses
[Musique]
nami tu fais quoi là palpable
une grande nouvelle à vous annoncer je
suis un sound pardon j et coll
oh